what do galaxies cloud formations your
nervous system mountain ranges and
coastlines all have in common
they all contain never-ending patterns
known as fractals
a classic example of a fractal when
Nature is broccoli in that the whole
stalk is a similar version of one of its
branches so cut off one piece and you're
left with a smaller version of the
entire broccoli snowflakes are another
example it's often said that no two
snowflakes are ever the same
the term fractal was coined by Benoit
mandelbrot who was working at computer
giant IBM in 1980. fractal geometry is
currently applied in many fields for
example Research into climate change and
the trajectory of dangerous meteorites
helping with cancer research by helping
to identify the growth of mutated cells
it's even believed by some that the
universe itself may be a fractal some
believe that due to their highly complex
and mysterious nature the greatest use
of fractals is yet to be discovered